dick and I work together in the Goonies
and I was trunk as a little chunky kid
but then I met a childhood actors
greatest nemesis puberty and I started
to thin out and I was less chunky so I
couldn't get work and I was despondent
because I just wanted to be an actor and
I couldn't get work and and you know I
talked to dick about it no I didn't
realize at the time that I was actually
beginning the long evolution from chunk
to the hunk that stands before you today
but at the time I was despondent and
dick Donner said in that big beautiful
voice it could it's okay kid work for me
there's a whole other side of show
business work for me I want to show you
about the business side of show business
kid and uh there was nothing in it for
him there's no way I could help him but
he let me work for him
and when I was in high school I would
work for him
over the summer and eventually I was
like okay well academics that's you know
that's going to be my future that's
where I can you know find a way to
contribute to show business you know
through dick helping me learn about the
business side of it
and I was going to apply to just the
college and I said he dick I said I'm
applying to college so um you know uh
you know would you mind writing a letter
of recommendation for me
he said sure kid he's like but show me
your essay so I know what to write you
know based on your essay said okay great
give him my essay when I'm gonna apply
to college and I talked about you know
the ups and downs and growing up with my
mom and my sister and you know a
single-parent household in the valley
and kind of how I thought academics was
a way that I could you know contribute
to the entertainment industry again and
make my life better so he calls me a
couple days later I remember where I was
I remember what I felt he called me he
said hey kid said he dick uh he's like
so I read your essay oh Michael good I'm
like good okay great
he's like yeah so um you know don't
worry first of all you're going to get
into a great school you're a good kid
you know you're smart kid you're going
to get into a great school but you know
Lauren and I we read your essay and um
we're going to pay for college and as
shocked as you are imagine how shocked I
was
I remember where I was in my mom's house
in Woodland Hills I remember being in
shock I remember having to sit down I
remember feeling like wow there's going
to be like a this burdens off of me
because now I can focus on my school I'm
not gonna have to worry about paying
what this is this is unbelievable and
and and I I didn't know I didn't know
what to say and that moment was a
turning point for me in my life
because I went from being despondent to
saying wow I'm special dick and Lauren
are smart they put a bet on me I can win
I can do this I have to make them proud
and from that moment my life changed and
dick has been with me and Lauren as well
helping me a hundred different ways
along the way from getting my first
entertainment law job out of college so
when I started my own firm helping me
plant that flag to you know personal
advice professional advice and there was
nothing in it for them
but they were kind and it made my life
better and I'm grateful that I got to
work with dick and the Goonies
but I'm far more grateful for his
friendship so dick I love you you
deserve all this this is amazing